استقبل الرئيس الاوكراني
بزيه العسكري في واشنطن استقبال الابطال
ويبدو ان ما حصل خلال هذه الزياره التي
بدات سريه وانتهت باستقبال تاريخيا في
الكونجرس ازعج موسكو كثيرا
قال ان الولايات المتحده منخرطه في تاجيج
الاوضاع في دول الاتحاد السوفيتي السابقه
منذ مده طويله واشار في نفس الوقت الى ان
كل النزاعات المسلحه تنتهي بالتفاوض وان
هدف روسيا ليس اطاله امد الصراع العسكري
وانما انهائه وكل ما كان ذلك اسرع كان
افضل
وبخصوص الصواريخ باتريوت قال بوتين بتهكم
انها صوره قديمه لا تعمل مثل صواريخ اس
300 الروسيه وان روسيا ستاخذ ذلك بعين
الاعتبار وستجد وسيله لابطال مفعولها
واضاف ان القوات الروسيه ستدمر هذه
الصواريخ اذا نقلت الى اوكرانيا يعلق
الرئيس الروسي على اعلان الاداره
الامريكيه خلال زياره زيننسكي واشنطن
تسليم اوكرانيا صواريخ ضمن مساعدات بقيمه
مليار و800 مليون دولار تشمل اسلحه دقيقه
اخرى وفيما يبدوك تقييم لهذه الزياره
قالبسكو انه بكل اسف للرئيس بايضا ولا
الرئيس زينسكي يتقى كلمات تشير الى
استعداد
في روسيا واضاف ان هذا يدل على ان
الولايات المتحده تواصل حربها غير
المباشره مع روسيا حتى اخر اوكراني
اما في الولايات المتحده فقد رد منسقوا
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي على تصريحات
المسؤولين الروس بالقول انه لا يحق لاحد
اي جمله على الولايات المتحده نوعيه
المساعدات الامنيه التي تقدمها لاوكرانيا
واضاف ان واشنطن تركز الان على تزويد
اوكرانيا بمعدات الدفاع الجوي بسبب الشتاء
وبسبب تغيير بوتن تكتيكه العسكري وكشف
كربي عن ان الرئيسينكي بحث فكره السلام
العادل كمبدا لانهاء الحرب
المبتغى من زيارته واختار توقيتها بعنايه
فهي تاتي في بدايه فصل الشتاء وفي وقت
تشهد فيه المعارك على الارض منعطف مهما
كما تاتي قبيله تسلل من جمهوريين رئاسه
مجلس النواب الامريكي مع العلم ان عدد من
قادتهم يبدون تحفظا بشان المساعدات
الكبيره التي تقدمها واشنطن لكيف وبعدهم
قال انه لن يسلم شكرا يا شيكا على بياض